[Music]
all right everyone thanks for coming by
for this end game class and today I pick
an end game that I found pretty
fascinating to start off it was played
between former world champion Mack Silva
from the Netherlands and Canada's first
Grand Master avian auskey for those who
don't know I came from Canada to rather
learn to play chess but I've also lived
in the Netherlands a lot of my good
chest friends are from there a lot of my
chest cultures from there I still go
there regularly so two of my favourite
countries for chess and yeah let's begin
so and this was played in 1946 in front
again in the Netherlands it was right
after World War two it was a first big
international event after World War two
so had a lot of strong players almost
everybody once the war finished so in
this position this is where we're
beginning White's up to pawns as you can
see and it's black to move and avian
oski Daniel is what it says on the score
sheet but he's Canada's first
Grandmaster and yeah he was 21 at the
time so he was a one of the lowest rated
players or on just a big underdog in
this field and here he is playing from
behind in his endgame down to pawns he
plays the first move correctly so you're
down to pawns here opposite bishops so
you know those drawing chances it's hard
to always remember when you know when
it's drawn when it's not but you know
that you should put your pawns on the
color you know opposite of your
opponent's Bishop because then they
can't be captured so he starts off
correctly h5 now two pawns
to founds is sometimes winning and
sometimes it is in opposite Bishop end
games when there are split pawns it's
often pretty bad but when they're
connected like this well we can see here
that white can't win by force
necessarily
I could I could demonstrate that by by
making a move like be for that wasn't
played but I played Bishop d3 now
forcing white to go a7 and now Bishop
efore and there's no way just with the
pond those pawns can queen or get
through and that's why you know there is
a high tendency to draw so h5 a good
start and now obey plays King f2 just
getting his King into the game you
thought yeah I mean he's not going to
leave g2 hanging but it's a good useful
first move there's a couple ideas
attached to that g3 might seem like the
other obvious move but you might want to
retain the option of something else
which I'm going to get to looking up to
bring the King into the game as well
and now Bishop d3 by black there are a
lot of options in this position the
objective assessment that I'm going to
show is probably I think this is a draw
with best play and adding the players
sort of have that feeling but of course
it's only white who can win so you know
it's not like a moment where white is
trying to calculate and find the win I
think he's just trying to gang up to
it's just a natural move here it's not
the calculation part yet black plays
Bishop d3 a couple other moves that
could be in played just from the very
beginning actually King King e6
instead of h5 is not good so I want to
show there is there is h5 was an
important move to gain some space to put
those pawns of light squares after King
e6 what I thought g4 now maybe that's
why white black boots black those aged 5
to also stop white from playing g4 this
is a very very annoying move because now
it's very hard for black to set up some
sort of light square blockade for
example okay you would never want to
play h6 you want to put the palms on
your color you don't want to play g5
to make it clear black can't really lose
the pond on the kingside to have passed
pawns on two different sides should be
just absolutely lost but a move like g6
to move like g6 King F - I'm not very
happy playing g6 because I don't play g6
with h5 well this is just very weak and
maybe white is actually going to be able
to at some point use those dark squares
and and penetrates and when h7 at some
point none of whites light squared
palms are at risk because I mean if this
bishop ever tries to harass I'm just
going to play a7 and they'll never
really be attacking my King's dead bonds
so g4 would have been extremely annoying
and just to demonstrate like h6 each for
this is I think just immediately lost
I'm just going to play h5 maybe put my
Bishop on d4 and you're paralyzed
so h5 already like that was a good move
King F to Bishop d3 this is a good move
just to force forced upon go to a 7
because as it is right now you know
there is potential if I get the time I'm
going to play d4 if I can get in b5 with
my phone and a6 then I can actually just
push the pawn all the way through
potentially so it's a move you're gonna
have to play at some point so King
that's - Bishop d3 a7 Bishop c4 and now
this is where white decided played g3
and because ok we're not at a moment yet
where we can sacrifice like of course I
would happily sacrifice any of the
kingside pawns if I could get a queen or
get my King in but it's not you know
there's nothing nothing immediate it
should take G - it's not like it's not
like White's King gets there really
quickly yeah I mean it pretty much needs
to reach reach b8 so not really close to
sacrificing pawn yet
besides that okay maybe throwing a move
like d4 but g3p three he has a plan in
mind and you know offski sort of falls
right for it so first of all King e6 was
played in the game I mean aren't too
many other moves you're going to move
the bishop g5 is another move that is
tempting and this is sort of instructive
if black can fix the Kings side then
this should be a draw then is King
concern I mean if I'm just going to make
some moves let's say g5 I'm going to get
some sort of sort of six position here
if blocking at the King to the Queen
side let's say on a in time now it
depends on a position then this should
be a drop because white doesn't have the
capacity to win any of the King side
palms unless you know it's a very
specific position but I'm just saying
imagine this King was on a this Bishop
was on eat white should never be able to
create a past one on the Kings side and
on the Queen side of the pawns already
on dark squares you should never be able
to you know get to be 70 so that's a
common common way that I think people
try to draw these positions but instead
he went for the more flexible King King
e6 there's nothing nothing quite wrong
with that after King III this is already
where a big blunder happened and
probably black was a little bit relaxed
because we we know that a lot of these
end games are drawn in and it's not
necessarily memorization you're just
like sort of told to keep the bishop on
the diagonal but after this game he
realizes a bit more dangerous Bishop g2
was played by an offski and it was
already losing
mistake and what we're going to do in
this game I was going to show what
happened and then sort of backtrack and
look at how both sides could have maybe
played better based on the understanding
that we learn from the game itself so
there are a bunch of moves that I've
sort of gone past that I'm going to
revisit the Bishop g2 was played and why
do you mean Utley plays King out four
and it's the king king wants to get to
g5 at some point I can ask from here let
me hide it can anybody identify a plan
for white here to try to make progress
try to create a passed pawn or any-any
winning fun again I mean those blocks
centralized King and there's Bishop
you're not winning on the Queen side not
yet you can use the pawn on a7 but yeah
King King up for makes a lot of sense I
mean White's playing the improving moves
anyways
but it helps to have a plan if you don't
have a plan king of four is a pretty
safe move of course
so think we can all agree probably king
of four make sense first that also stops
black remember playing g5 or something
and then we can maybe do Bishop before
we can try to provoke some more
weaknesses so King up for was was played
King at five was a big improvement over
Bishop g2 not to let the King get to
that square not to let the King get that
square you know in some ways you might
have been concerned that as king of
getting a bit further away from the
Queen side but the King on f4 the king
going to the King side first was
surprisingly effective intuitively to me
I'm sort of looking at how do I get my
King to be eight or something like that
but you do need to it it's too simple to
look at it we can't get our queen to our
King to be it's just not possible
so Bishop g2 came to f4 g6 is played put
I mean you know there's that's pretty
self-explanatory it's going to have to
move at some point and now g4 here and
this is a pretty critical move so one
thing we can definitely conclude this
Bishop is stuck on this diagonal so
unless the blacks King is a capable
defender but I can't really leave any
pawns stranded so right now there's a
pretty simple threat of gjx h5g takes a
Chad King g5 I'll just demonstrate that
for example and here Bishop that's
reasonable to descent but I'll happily
give up one pawn because the H in the D
pawn without the bishops is is a very
basic win the King and Bishop can't
really stop the these these split pawns
especially when they're so far apart I'm
going to distract the bishop with one
pond and use my king bishop another bond
to be the king and you we don't have to
worry about any pawns on the wrong color
here this is the right color and this is
on the B file so it doesn't matter so
there's no sort of draw in that sense so
this is just an elementary win and both
players knew that so you can't leave any
pawns hanging like that because yeah I
will happily give this up it's much
harder for blacks to stop split pawns
here then then connected pawns when
you've already been committed like that
there's fortresses so g4 is a I mean the
forces h6g for if H I mean this would
just run into King g5 so black takes
white captures and Bishop h1
there's not a lot of variety for black
to choose from
King g5 again here I'll give it up I
will give it up or I can even wait to
give it up by the way I would like to
say you can throw in additional moment
as well
each for maybe four and try to speed up
the process because black doesn't have
anything useful to do in the meantime
so h4b for those moves are fine to throw
and that should be better actually
so the King up seven this should be four
so now keeping the King stuck on f7
forcing the bishop to move Bishop g2
it's already I mean this position is is
already lost but can anyone tell me why
anyone give me a plan so we've got like
almost everything ideal here we still
don't have another pot spun which would
make things easy but what does King h6
threaten yeah no because if black black
can't move the King what are the king's
enough but the bishop will just keep
moving
you might be tempted to play Bishop
before because you want it for your
picking I mean it doesn't free it up in
the long run because if the King never
moves away from f7 we also have the
additional plan of sacrificing the upon
and winning the g6 pawn but you also
have to deal with moves such as King up
four and let's just say we we move back
to H one teeny five and now we were
forcing we're either getting our King to
be eight or we're going to achieve that
other winning method which is the split
box so I mean at this point black smooth
it's past the point of no return Bishop
g2 h4
Bishop h1 and I mean this is why black
is doing Bishop H 1 V 2 V 2 because if
King at 4 I will play King e6 so the
King's not getting in there
so after Bishop H 1 how do we continue
to make progress I mean they're
paralyzed if you don't know what to do
yes we can throw in V 4
okay we can even throw in d5
will you throw in v6 as well
I mean it doesn't change the evaluation
of the position we're going to take a
look at this v6 after I'm glad somebody
somebody said let's storm v6 I might be
time to play b6 - there are some
situations where you don't want to do
that and we're going to look at this
later so keep that b6 move in mind
white-white has a plan
I'm in the king I'm just moving my
bishop to g2 and h1 how to take away the
g2 square if you get your king of g3 I
can move it to other parts of the board
that's what I mean and then as soon as
your King moves from g3 I put it back to
each one so I'm glad that nobody's come
up with a plan because it means it's pro
oh yeah and how would you die right now
so that is an interesting idea sacrifice
the H bond to play King f5 because if
you do that I'm going to probably just
keep marching my H pawn I'm just saying
if you were to do that right now she's
not sure about to move order but it's an
interesting suggestion h5 it takes King
takes our run liking the a this is a
dead draw or even without if you play
King at 5 here maybe I should just try
to sacrifice that bond anyways because
you probably have to play they should be
5 at some point to stop upon from
getting too far but I mean we do not
have that many options so that that
suggestion is definitely interesting
is
I mean we're not winning on the
queenside blacks King is even if we
bring around the other way
this isn't you know too connected past
bonds like this we we can't force I mean
we'd have to get our King to literally
be it because even the parking is on v6
a king black skin could be on see it we
can't really force it in I mean it's not
pardon me yeah this is about six it's
about six
so the Bishop g2 which is played will
first of all they should be for just
want to reiterate we can play this move
and then get our King to e5 and then go
a king to d6 especially because this
Bishop now cover some squares but this
would be two obviously because that's
what black black has been relying on so
Bishop g2 h 5g Jake age five and king of
five
so the bishop on f6 covers h4 it covers
da the king here can jump City six of
black ever tries to run the King over I
mean the game finished here I mean this
was this should at six is nothing
nothing you can do against this plan
there's nothing like so it was lost a
long time ago I thought is a very nice
way to finish it so Bishop b4 wait
bishop you - yeah h5 you know something
like this pretty picturesque now okay
that didn't take too long but what I
found interesting about this game is
analyzing afterwards how blacks could
have improved the play and maybe how I
could improve the players so this this
is maybe a new technique to some of you
guys on how to I mean box the King out
like this or or converted its act like
this is a fairly I haven't seen this
idea used too many times and white took
took his chances but I want to go back
now and and see at what point was really
lost and what you know both sides should
have done better because I mean this was
once we got this position we knew this
like if black doesn't have any moves
besides Bishop each one Bishop g2 but
it's just a matter of white finding
applying and there is this Bishop f6 h5
which can never be stopped in the long
run yeah getting leaking to f5 I mean so
if we don't have that plan and actually
I want to go over that that's something
I had prepared so we're going to go all
the way back and I'm not a big endian
guy so this actually first of all two
players I'm interested in and plus it's
the topic of the class it forced me to
do more in-game work they normally do
which is probably good for me so we're
going to go back from the very beginning
this is a you know we analyze an endgame
we saw very nice conversion by over but
it wasn't winning from the start so h5
first move was all that was okay
King F to the ship d3 actually wasn't a
problem in e7 Bishop before because now
at least very defined and the black
doesn't allow that plan that we just saw
I'm not sure about a breakthrough
yep it should be to the blunder later on
but I'm not there yet I mean yeah this
is a question or I mean after Bishop d2
we get our King to f4 and I don't think
we missed we didn't miss anything there
but the ship sufficiently for happens
nothing wrong with this and I I've seen
this scheme from two different sources
I've seen it when I looked up Janoski
games because he's kind of suscribe
master and I also saw I think covered in
directive wretzky one of his books at
one point marked a wretzky name is
Russian trainer and and so I decided to
look it up a little bit and at this
point I'm not sure if I don't think I've
seen comments but a very interesting
idea for white is to play g4 right now
and the reason why I want to play G for
now so gene for h6g for King g3 I want
to get into the same sort of position we
got into before where I have an itch fun
against Blacks Jeep on and at some point
blacks going to play g6 and we should be
able to do the same thing if something
like Bishop f3 well h3 is the move
although h3 let's take a look at h3 I
thought this is interesting so h3 let's
just say they play King e6 and we just
take back what's the difference between
this end game and with each pawn instead
of G pawn for white well we don't have
the h5 move so we can't get to f5 so
let's say we get into we get into
something very similar we don't have the
h5 move and if king of for King e6 so I
think this is a draw at least that was
my first impression and it made a lot of
sense we if we can't get to the f5
square which we could force before I
mean see in this case yeah black blocks
way of messing up is to play Bishop b4
and allow us to you know sort of
infiltrate like that but as long as
black doesn't do that well sometimes
just let them sort of something I
believe it does say there's no great
through but I I'm not a huge table base
for endgame expert but I based on what
was winning in in the original game and
I didn't see another way to win this
seems to me like it's a draw yeah
well if you ever get your getting to a
six presumably my king is on CA by that
point nine it's only I'm only three
moves away from getting to to c8
I mean there's a lot of if we take these
pawns off the board and and I mean two
pawns to connected pawns but what the
pun already on a seven this is like
always a drop always the draw is up in
one case there's way to mess up but I
mean blacks King is always faster to the
square where there's no way we get to a
six quickly I mean the only way quick is
to get to d6 well then we're going to go
to be a anyways I mean there's no way to
get to a six I mean black black
streamers away from getting the c8 which
means we'll never get to see it you
never get b7 now I think this is a draw
but g4 itself is a very good move but
it's quite deep King up for I went a
little bit further the bishop is stuck
on f3 right because if it moves I take
g4 we transpose to the game which I I
think we establish is winning so let's
say they try to keep the spawn and they
keep moving I think I went a little bit
further I play the King at four okay I
put the pond on h3 but it sort of
doesn't matter the bishop is stuck on f3
because it's trying to stop us from
playing King takes three four not eight
six three four g6 and let's just say
something like here and the funny thing
is this eventually gets into some sort
of it gets into some sort of xiguan
like this
why because the king can't move and the
bishop can't move so the only thing you
can move is the pawn I know this is very
deeper than we just f king up for
recovering g1 and we can force the
endgame we just had we're going to win
the g3 pawn we're gonna bring our King
back to g5 and it's winning and I don't
think I saw that anywhere before so
that's what white should have done but
you wouldn't necessarily you know that's
I don't know the time control things
like that it's not it's a lot easier for
me to study at home than to play but
here so he played g3 King e6 King here
and now King f5 there's no break through
here this is this should be a draw he
just played King f5 a sample line they
should essayed g6 so our usual setup
that I think we can all understand we
put our pawns on g6 h5 but our King is
on out at 5 so it's a little bit leans a
bit a little bit more towards the Kings
side which might seem unnatural but once
you've seen the plan that white actually
uses the king side to win it's a lot
easier to understand if we try to make a
run for it now with the King on f5 it's
still not in time still not in time and
this is the best version we get what I
mean we got our king to g4 with our King
on f5 but because there's a part of me
saving with chief force which is a good
thing to do
you need that extra pass pong or or you
need to the lane this is now this is
this is back to more much more basic
endgame you can't make a breakthrough
here what I didn't know so you guys
remember while back I said would you
keep pushing your pawn to d6 right and I
said we're going to go back to the d6
point what's the benefit of not pushing
the pawn to d6 we take a position like
this and I get ya this position right
here the Kings on b6 instead of upon and
this is you know this is the king and it
seems to be about as bad as that as it
can be I don't see a way to is winning
or lost drunks are winning a drawn
well with the King on v6 they should all
you should always block the clean square
with your bishop in this specific
position or play King see it because if
you just think that it's a draw which
I've done myself I've actually made this
mistake online playing quickly I thought
once I get this position just imagine
these pawns are off the board by the way
just imagine they're off the board or
six or something I mean we're not white
it white can only play on the Queen side
right now if I just make a pass thinking
that you can Queen wait I need to make a
couple more passes here here something
like this with the King on b6 not upon
you I mean I was looking oh you can you
can do this Queen and I didn't know
about this either
and the whole point is that square that
the king always wants to go on it's not
pushing this again that's just an easy
draw you get your king to d8 and I'm
just going to push b6 and b7 and black
cannot get two pieces the King and
Bishop on it I mean the thing is I
haven't had too many theoretical end
games with two million games like in
German practice where these things may
apply but it's good to know because it's
an additional trick your opponent can
fall for promote like you know let's say
you're a long time it's very easy to
just forget to play the cautious move
here something like king CA then there's
no chance of this at all and this is a
draw but just you know moving back and
forth so having that King on b6 helps
there's an additional benefit so I
probably wouldn't push my king to b6
after seeing that so back to this back
to this so what's the conclusion your
king of five king at five and it should
be a draw but what that means in the
very beginning position is g4 puts a lot
of stress on blacks position I mean that
I think yeah I mean I realized only
shortly before the study for maybe
position is already lost here so that's
not what I read when I looked over this
game in other comments without other
comments well generally you don't want
to put your pawns on the color of your
opponent's bishops I play h3 remember
this Bishop is stuck on this diagonal so
it's a good point to bring up what
happens at age four but this Bishop is
stuck so I don't mind putting my upon an
h3 because you'll never be able to
capture it but I now I just have it
pretty your King has to at some point
I'm going to win the pawn
the dark Spurs I mean it's what did you
play g5 or whatnot
your king is now your king
well I'll just I'll just make a few
moves I'm threatening to things I'm
threatening to get a bishop on this
diagonal and pick up the spawn or turn
into my King on b8 and you can't start
both with one King so if you just can't
do it and this one here like then I mean
I'm going to play here and we're going
to have a very similar endgame that
white dem like that white one in the
game here I'm running it to get my king
the g5 and force the trade you know
something like this
don't play Bishop Bishop here and should
be winning should be winning
so I thought I mean I was following some
comments maybe here King e6 is is the
better choice first but the endgame
extremely hard to hold but those are a
couple of ways for white to to win an
opposite Bishop endgame I haven't seen
that technique too much and I thought
try to be pretty pretty interesting
there's definitely definitely of course
makes it a lot harder for the defending
side when there's pawns on both side to
the board because as I said if this was
on just one side this is just with
theoretical draw but you you actually
play on the you have this idea of
playing on the King side here which I
haven't seen too much any questions
about the game any moments to go back on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]